What did you think of the Pico fight?
Oh Man.
So unfortunate.
Crazy,
right?
Because he's just,
he's such a killer that he wants to knock everyone out.
Not only does he want to be the best fighter in the world,
but he wants to be the most entertaining fighters in the world.
So he's looking to punish you because he's got so many weapons that he doesn't
use.
Um,
he's so good man.
but he lives by the sword and he dies by the sword kind of thing.
You know,
he wants to be that,
that knock you out entertaining fight or he wants to be able to show a highlight
reel,
first round knockouts,
you know,
um,
which is great.
Yeah.
But you always have to understand that you are just like the guy right in front
of you.
Yeah.
And then one shot,
especially in MMA,
one shot can turn it all around.
And it did.
It was one of the most shocking knockouts or think I've ever seen because it
looked like he looked fucking phenomenal.
He came out there and we knew that he had been trading with you for this fight.
Who was fucking shredded.
He looked like a world beater.
Yeah.
Went out there and landing that clean up or caught and then got just way carried
away.
Yup.
And it's unfortunate because you think I'm in shape and I do crazy things.
This guy's putting me to shame like at in Sam's garage,
but he's able to do on the bike and just his workout regimen and like just how
competitive he is.
Man.
He's a,
he's a world beater.
He could be by far will champion,
you know,
there's some things that he's so young,
so there's some things we need to get to figure out.
Everyone takes losses and uh,
help them.
One of these is going to spark him to realize how good he is everywhere,
you know?
And uh,
it's just an unfortunate situation.
MMA.
Yeah.
I mean guys have bounced back from knockouts and become world champions
unquestionably.
It's just,
he's got to make sure it doesn't have too many of those,
you know,
and make sure we fight smart.
The grade [inaudible] use that goddamn wrestling too.
It's insane risks.
I mean,
he's so good as a wrestler and when he gets that guy hurt,
he's collar tie there.
They're grabbing each other by neck and just swinging shots.
You're,
you're flipping a coin,
you're rolling the dice once he got six fights or something like that.
Yeah.
I mean,
it's one of those inexperienced things and he's only 22.
Yeah.
I mean,
that's the other thing.
And you realize like when he dropped me,
could've jumped on him.
He could have swarmed him like Hillary did to me,
you know,
like jump on them and swarm them and look for that finish.
But,
um,
definitely I think the inexperienced kind of makes him realize like maybe he's
invincible and just,
I don't know,
man.
There's,
there's things that you kind of figure out when you've been out in the cage and
longer and longer,
and you've been around the crew,
you understand there's ways to finish a fight or,
or how to,
how to just be a smart fighter.
Yeah.
They,
he'll figure out.